[Music]
if I ran a Nintendo today I'd probably
put out five thousand pieces of creative
content starring Zelda and Mario and
build up the IP and make sure all those
characters and all those visions would
be winning on tick-tock Instagram
YouTube I would just produce its scale
this has now become singularly a making
game make make make make you got your
perspective if you were to give a
percentage of your work like home life
balance what would it be you think the
balance is but I also think that balance
absent flows so I'm probably spending
more time on my life right now than ever
I mean look I in all people look at
things funny between a - between being
fully all-in on weekends between five
other weeks of vacation during the year
like you're already at a place where
you're talking about you only work 225
of the 306 you know like you know like
people are very funny about how they
think about work-life balance like I
think that for me somebody who enjoys
work between those vacations and
weekends and now my kids are getting
older so now it is go to a soccer match
in the middle of the day which is super
foreign to me like I used to be 90 M
midnight every minute boom so but again
I think it's similar to not judging
myself that somebody's upset this
morning like you can only do your best
and I think one of the biggest
weaknesses in our society is that people
beat themselves up at every single
second instead of looking at it in a
year's worth or a life's work or at
least a month's work and so I think
balance is important I also think
everybody here has different balance
some people think nine-to-five is
balance I would hate my life if I work
9:00 to 5:00 it's just too much downtime
for me I enjoy what I do too much so you
get to define balance
you get the judge yourself and people
literally take the opinions of their
parents and friends into how they parent
or work-life balance that is so
laughable too much peer pressure too
much judgment I have no idea a
hypothesis I have definitely his voice
is gonna be a player I definitely
believe that the new interface that's
brewing his voice and its impact will be
as large as the mobile device when at
scale 15 17 years from now I'm not
packed you know I get a lot of credit
because of the way I invested in all the
documentation of being write a lot but
what I try to remind people is when I
was saying those things it had already
happened I'm not predicting tick-tock it
has 1.5 billion downloads the [ __ ] kind
of guesses that it's just that people
love to say no about today let alone the
future not worried about a our
blockchain
you know ml you know VR all that's
coming I'm watching all of it but no
real people use it yet
and so people love to jump the gun on
technology advancements ahead of the
consumer behavior
I am blindly a day trader of this second
before I worry about how to get you know
my a our capabilities down why not
maximize the [ __ ] out of today right
this second
you know LinkedIn tik-tok Instagram
grossly underpriced advertising has
always been the leading edge of in
culture so AR has to and VR has to begin
to weave its way in and as advertising
agencies do we have to be at the
forefront align in a practical way the
reason I've been able to do that is cuz
I'm willing to make less money you know
not super complicated back to CFO CFO
walks in and says I want to shut down
the voice department like then shut down
the whole company he's like but it's not
profitable
I'm like I'm aware that's the punchline
the reason most agencies aren't able to
pull it off is because they don't want
to give up the march in that year you're
not gonna have clients often paid to
subsidize you know those new
advancements but I think the key is to
not be too far and advanced so we do
have people flirting with a R and B
aren't things that nature but it is
flirting because it's just not close I
don't think people realize how not close
be ours I don't know a single person
that knows a single person that spends
an hour a day in a vr environment every
person spends seven hours a day in a
phone turn about a real Delta so yeah to
me it's the speed in adjusting to what
the consumers done what I'm proud of is
as soon as musically gets bought by
tick-tock
they relaunch stuff starts happening our
ability at being her to be a creative on
that depart in that world within moments
of it becoming real that's the strength
more than predicting it's the speed in
which you can execute in today versus
the variable of being right about
tomorrow we talked a little bit before
the livestream started about how you've
scaled your company and you know just
from from a cultural standpoint but also
from a process standpoint from a an
accountability standpoint could you
speak yes it's a human game you know you
know from a cultural standpoint from a
process standpoint it's just judging the
judgers you know at my level I think I
think people are very naive on how much
the variable of success is predicated on
the CEO you know like she or he has a
whole lot of say there's a judge in the
jury a CEO is basically the Supreme
Court you know like it's pretty final
these are dictatorships you know
obviously there's boards and some
companies that may have a little juice
but the reality is is that you know the
way we've done it is by actually caring
about it you know it's not super
complicated
I would work far more advanced on
culture than process I hate process so
much that I look at it often and any
time I do look on it it looks like it's
going really poorly
and so then I just cry and go to sleep
and so um you know you achieve our
office we deal with cheap processors we
don't and and I think that there's a
couple reasons and we won't I believe
that human beings that work in companies
are disproportionally obsessed with
process and I think the second you start
putting the process in front of the
output you lose and I think almost every
company puts the process in front the
output I'd rather the process be murky
and breakable then put on a pedestal
it's a tricky one it's a tricky one but
if you listen to what I just said what
you'll learn is it will come down to
casting and if you work on culture and
people aren't political with each other
and jerks they'll figure it out much
easier and with less friction but the
reality is most agencies have too much
process and way too much insecurity and
politics and thus it's slow and clunky
and crabby
so I think I think I'll answer the
second one first it's about data privacy
regulations can handle a world where AI
where every single product is smart
that's scale two decades from now which
is the assumption or guess that I have
right now uh no but I think there's a
much bigger conversation around data
privacy that's not being had which is I
actually don't think people care about
the privacy I think there's a much more
thoughtful conversation going on that
will eventually play out which is I'm
gonna I'm gonna predict that it's gonna
go the other way I would prefer that
every technology knew everything about
me I mean it unless you kill my children
or steal my money
I'd prefer you know everything this
notion of privacy what privacy are we
actually talking about what websites I
went on my credit card number you give
away your credit card number every day
everywhere like Target and the IRS had
much bigger breaches than Facebook
you know like I think there's this
fun narrative right now to demonize
technology because we don't like being
accountable like the Russians didn't
make you vote for someone you did you
decided to believe you know and so this
huge lack of accountability will play
out so I'm not you know look if somebody
is creeped out that the refrigerator
reordered their milk because the milk
spoke to the refrigerator and said we
have one pour left they're more than
welcome to not I keep reminding people
I'm like don't have a smartphone Gary
this all sucks it's all terrible like
delete Facebook I did I'm like right
you're on Instagram yeah but I like it I
mean so look I think it's an agency when
you think about this mortification
you're talking about building you're
talking about actually being in death
which is not a big passion of mine
ironically I don't like building the
highways I like driving them better than
anybody else
so I think when you talk about smart
ofin where it's all gonna lead to is
brand brand is gonna become the most
important thing because when you're
watering on a voice device you better
say Kleenex not tissues you better say
Nike not sneakers because then then
Amazon or Google are gonna pick for you
right same thing with brand once I put
that Pepsi in that fridge that fridge is
reordering Pepsi not me deciding to pick
up coke at an end cap at Walmart so
brand is I can't yell about it enough
like look at my own behaviors the
signature the sonic branding like this
is all branding for me you know like all
my friends call me a sucker for giving
away the 270 page deck the other day not
me
I think about brand you feel warmer
towards me I did something nice for you
people don't get it so that's how I see
you know I think privacy is really funny
like I think Europe is a really miss is
really miss playing the world
I think Europe's you're growing
irrelevance has a lot to do with the
defense they have around all this stuff
when Google and Facebook and all these
other companies that don't want to be
there that's going to be bad not good
how do you obviously putting out a lot
of content over so many different
platforms so my question is how do you
measure the success of that is it based
on purely likes and as we start to see
likes going away
likes will go away only for our
insecurities outward but we will still
see them on the back end but keep going
my my measure my measurement on success
is far more qualitative because I'm
trying to win on brand I'm not trying to
sell case with sneakers I know that I
sold a thousand pairs yesterday I'm this
singular Instagram post but that is not
where my mind goes on is that good or
bad
my mind works this way when I went to
the airport last weekend a
seven-year-old ran up to me and asked
for a selfie I knew tick-tock was
working so for me it's qualitative I
know something's working based on
reading the comments at scale so for me
it's much more the comments themselves
not how many comments the interpretation
of the intent of the of the comments
because I'm building brand I'm not
worried about how many likes and shares
I thought so years ago but much like I
knew Google+ wasn't gonna work because
it wasn't in Google's DNA I Facebook has
not shown to me that search is
inherently in their collective DNA I'm
shocked that Facebook is not a bigger
search player given the scale that they
had given how great the data could have
been not as confident as I used to be
but that's what's great about everything
you can reboot anything they can hire
one great executive from Google and she
could drive it I there's a whole lot of
interesting data that I'd love to search
that's public in facebook from a search
engine standpoint so but I do think
certain companies have certain DNA's you
know
please this is not an answer
Google just released they're like yep
yep do you envision like basically
within the next decade
we're now see you like gaming yes Google
will absolutely go into dynamic gaming
ads they just need to have the control
of the inventory so they've got to win
the IP game because if they have to go
through Blizzard or somewhere else
they've got a problem whoever owns the
IP wins that game right otherwise
they're gonna have to pay a huge big to
the game creator to get in there and
then by nature the ad won't be
inherently native because there'll be a
friction between two different companies
almost like creative and media so I
think Google but I think what people
forget is how big these companies are
like Google can buy one of the top
gaming studios in the world but yes I do
gaming is people are extremely naive
about where gaming is in our society
like eSports is easily one of the top
three sports in America in 15 years with
basketball and soccer being the other
two that have the most up side whereas
football is stagnant even though it's
America's past passion and hockey and
baseball continue to decline I mean the
five best baseball players in America
could walk into this office right now
and 95% us audience would not know who
they are
they'd be like those are some
good-looking buff dudes
but they wouldn't know that it's Mike
Trout and he's the best player the best
and when you're in a place where the dis
by the way not only is Mike Trout the
best player in baseball he's probably
gonna go down as one of the best players
of all time and the fact that half the
audience doesn't even know who that is
is a real big problem for baseball and
that by the way this is a good lesson
for digital agencies and marketers and
business people
that's because baseball took the stance
a decade ago that they would create an
organization called BAM and they would
monetize every piece of content thus
every free piece of content on YouTube
and social media was taken down by major
league baseball plus baseball teams
couldn't do their own stuff nor could
players it was all controlled at a
central level to monetize they made a
lot of money in the short term but they
completely killed the brand of the sport
if I ran a Nintendo today I'd probably
put out five thousand pieces of creative
content starring Zelda and Mario and
build up the IP and make sure all those
characters and all those visions would
be winning on tik-tok Instagram YouTube
you have to make sure that Kid Icarus
and you know Megaman and all these
things reboot all that nostalgia brands
not just Mario and Zelda and then I
would innovate for games within the
environments of streaming like you know
like there's no reason that fortnight
couldn't have been predicated on
Nintendo characters so look at
multiplayer you know streaming games and
I would look at mobile games very
heavily for females because the IP
translates extremely well to the female
debt demo and I would just be
contemporary I'd probably start 10
original podcasts I would just produce
it's scale this has now become
singularly a making game make make make
make
right I think our final question we have
from one of the live streamers and from
si I digital is what will be the biggest
impact 5g will make in digital marketing
out of the gate and five years ahead
edie is it and I'm not really sure the
one thing that I really know about 5g so
I think it's funny how people think
about 5g most people if they're even
aware of it are like cool my phone will
be faster meanwhile this is a
transcending technology 5g will be the
reason that autonomous cars become real
because the lag time will be zero 5g is
the reason that a surgeon could be woken
up in Brazil tonight because she's the
best in the world at a certain surgery
and she can VR with 5g performing
surgery on you while you're in New
Jersey that's amazing so the speed in
which information moves is so incredible
I don't remember the exact fact but this
is not like from 4:00 to 5:00 this is
like from 4 to 40 or 4 to 400 I don't
remember if it's 10 X 400 but it's
profound so I think that the ability for
information to move with no lag is what
is really going to be profound things
like the you know when you start
thinking about technology where the
paint is smart some of things we talked
about with the refrigerator and things
of that nature are predicated on 5g
think about a world where our pavement
outside is smart and because a 5g can
speak to our car and your car actually
slightly moves so you don't hit the
puddle going 72 on the Turnpike which
mathematically would have meant you
would have lost control enough and
predicated on where all the other cars
were positioned to you it avoided an
accident for you
that's crazy ass [ __ ]
[Music]
IG
[Music]